[Musique]
c'est l'oeil d'un peintre mais aussi
celui d'un voyageur new york le japon ou
encore le mali la birmanie bernard
mérigots c'est l'artiste qui parcourt le
monde pourrait capter sur le vif une
ambiance une atmosphère
chaque voyage ça représente une couleur
une façon c'est presque deux techniques
différentes à chaque voyage quelques
fois on me le dit d'ailleurs on a
l'impression que ce n'est pas le même
peintre mais pas ce que je ressens pas
les mêmes choses d'un endroit
à chaque voyage son émotion mais
toujours ce même procédé
des morceaux de souvenirs fondu dans la
peinture
j'aime bien ce travail de collage
du fait que je travaille aussi beaucoup
par des voyages et j'achète des tissus
des papiers que je ramène de ses voyages
et je les colle sur mes tableaux loyer
je ramenais les papiers de couleurs du
tissu la toile de jute différentes
choses encore
imaginez les boubous les vêtements
différents et le quartier barbès le
musée beaubourg
peut être que dans quelques années j'y
reste posée là paris la dernière
inspiration du peintre peut-être un
retour aux sources pour ce parisien
installé depuis longtemps dans le loiret
bernard mérigots le peintre voyageur qui
offre de la matière matière à imaginer
matière à rêver
[Musique]